même regard kipling goûtant les délices
de l' empire des indes et bien nous nous
allons goûter un chapelet kebab alors le
chez lush applique cabab
ça rappelle le mot cabab ça rappelle un
peu kebab c'est pas très éloigné il faut
se souvenir que le pakistan se trouve à
la limite entre lisons le moyen-orient
et puis lorient donc entre le monde
arabe et le monde hindouistes et ce
péquiste en bas c'est normal il a hérité
un petit peu de plusieurs traditions
culinaires qui l'a mélangé faut par
exemple pas oublier que pendant très
longtemps les sikhs ont occupé le
pakistan est donc ce chapitre cabab
c'est de la viande en fait c'est une
sorte de hamburgers pakistanais sur des
boulettes de viande que l'on fabriqué
avec des ingrédients très facile à
trouver sur le marché français tout
d'abord des tomates des tomates que l'on
va des coupés en lamelles des oignons 6
passes et des petits oignons rouges que
l'on découpe en cubes des piments alors
des groupies mans vers des groupements
rouge des petits piments verts et des
petits piments rouges cela les petits
étant les plus forts bien sûr et puis du
coriandre du cumin alors normalement
c'est du cumin blanc mais en france on
trouve difficilement des cubains blanc
là on a pris ce chemin là que l'on va
mélanger avec du curcuma et puis on va
mettre de la farine de maïs et des oeufs
du beurre normalement il faudrait mettre
de la grèce de yack c'est à dire de la
grèce de buffle si vous préférez le yak
d'un buffet de montanes est très
pratique pour porter quand on fait de l'
escalade et puis ben en france c'est
pareil on a du mal à en trouver alors on
a mis du beurre de normandie du bon
beurre de levage de chez nous la même
chose pour la viande la viande c'est de
la viande de buffle ou de de yack mais
là c'est de la viande de boeuf ne pas
oublier le sel et le poivre
et puis pour manger ça pour en faire un
véritable hamburgers et bien on va
fabriquer des pins des pins pakistanais
que l'on appelle des pourris et qui sont
faits avec de la farine de maïs trois
quarts de farine de maïs et un quart de
farine de blé on mélange bien ça on en
fait une patte et on fait des petites
galettes comme ça que l'on va faire
évidemment cuir une fois qu'elles seront
cuitent on se servira de sa pour manger
c'est à dire qu'on attrapera la viande
dans la mettra là dedans et on mangera
karl avantages de la cuisine
pakistanaise aussi bien pour la préparer
que pour la manger c'est qu'il ya pas
besoin d'ustensiles uniquement à voir
ses deux mains si vous voulez bien alors
votre beurre est en train de prendre
pourquoi le destrier complètement et on
va vous prônez vous mettez sur le bord
deux hommes surtout ne pas laisser
chance il faut l'obliger comme ça voyez
où le mélange est en même temps dans la
grèce normalement de yack mais là je le
répète encore une fois il s'agit tout
simplement d'un vendeur de normandie
vous prenez vos boulettes que vous avez
préparé avant et que vous faites bien à
tourner que vous mélangez avec l'offre
avec le beurre avec les épices
évidemment il y en a eu auparavant on
rajoute de dans celle que ce matin
un peu d'oignons voilà on va pouvoir
commencer les uns que les autres qui
sont il faut bien séparer les oeufs
c'est quand même pas une omelette que
l'on sait on était une première partie
maintenant vous mettez des oignons
pourpres avoir peur mais les autres nous
laisse alors lèverait les marchands ils
sont très forts parce que ils font ça à
la main dans la poêle je sais pas
comment ils font de ce que c'est quand
même chose sur attention voilà vous
pouvez en mettre un petit peu de beurre
quand ça commence à trop johnny depp
pour rire dre l'étape de man se fait
calme un peu ça ne calmera pas votre
cholestérol c'est sûr mais quand même
voilà on remet quelques un petit peu sur
tous les côtés ont fui les oignons les
oignons qui m'ont fait pleurer
j'espère et même celle ci n'en sera pas
de même
voilà et maintenant tout ça crie vous
pouvez si vous le voulez si vous allez
bien épicée rajouter un peu de ce que
vous avez préparé
c'est à dire avec les piments de tout ça
c'est des concoctions très spéciale avec
duke oriente des piments et tous vous
tourner au boulet sans les défaire
voilà et où là maintenant comment bien
la ville voulait retirer avec votre
préparation
deux cents enfants vous les sortez de
leur lit pour qu'ils aillent directement
sur la poêle et faites cuire la de la
barre manche ça assez assez cuit c'est
pas vraiment le côté bleu rouge
évidemment faut adapter si vous aimez
quelque chose de saignant mardi fait
comme pour inditex aignan simplement
pour bien faire cuire pendant pas il
faut écarter les autres ingrédients
alors maintenant vous laisser un petit
peu de cuir et vous avez préparé
auparavant vos crêpes comme ça et c'est
avec ça qu'on appelle des pourris que
l'on va manger les morceaux moi j'aime
bien quand ces bleus alors j'en doute et
maintenant voyez on peut faire carrément
le hamburger celle vous mettez un petit
peu de tout ça attention les mains c'est
quand même assez chaud un d'un petit
gris comme ça et puis après vous pouvez
même aplatir un peu mobile est pour
qu'elles rentrent mieux voilà
mcdonald's n'a rien inventé
vous dire que c'est encore meilleur pour
les faire fuir insolites les aplatir un
peu on peut après les rencontres et
c'est toujours su pratiquer dans le
sandwich
voilà je voulais rajouter un peu
[Musique]